These are the four most powerful writing
frameworks that I've ever come across.
As an English professor and writing
coach, I've spent my career analyzing
the world's best writers. And what I'm
going to give to you here are four
writing patterns that, once you see
them, you're going to start spotting
them everywhere. So, today I want to
offer to you a writing framework that'll
help you keep your readers focused. A
framework that'll give your writing
momentum. A framework that'll help you
break down complex ideas into simpler
units. And a framework that'll help you
weave together multiple strands into a
single idea. Now, these frameworks are
not just style tips or my own list of
personal preferences. They're the
cognitive patterns that readers use to
interpret your text. And by analyzing
the writing patterns from the
perspective of reader psychology, it's
going to help you write more clearly
and, more importantly, more valuably.
So, to start, let's take a look at the
same passage written two different ways,
because this is going to let you in on
the principle that underlies all four
patterns. And so, the original passage
is taken from Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi.
Csikszentmihalyi. He's the guy who wrote
about flow. But before I get to his
original passage from the book Flow,
what I'd like to do is look at the same
passage written differently, because
it's the difference between them that's
going to help you see this principle
that we're talking about. So, my edit,
the bad version, says, "Things that
happen are not what produces happiness.
Good fortune and random chance don't
result in it, either. Money can't buy
it, and power can't command it. Outside
events do not determine it. Our
interpretation of those events does.
Preparation, cultivation, and private
defense by each person are what this
condition requires.
Now, if I asked you what was wrong with
that passage, it might be hard to say. I
mean, there's no grammar mistakes in it.
It has all the pieces that we need to
understand what he's talking about, but
something seems a little bit off. So,
let's contrast that with the original
from Csikszentmihalyi's book, which
says, "Happiness is not something that
happens. It is not the result of good
fortune or random chance. It is not
something that money can buy or power
command. It does not depend on outside
events, but rather on how we interpret
them. Happiness, in fact, is a condition
that must be prepared for, cultivated,
and defended privately by each person."
Now, speaking of flow, I think you'd
agree that that latter passage was a lot
easier to understand, and you might have
spotted the difference, but in case you
haven't, the key difference between
these two passages is that in the one
that's difficult to understand, we find
all these different elements organized
in the topic position at the start of
the sentence. We see things that happen,
good fortune, money, outside events,
preparation. And so, if you were to look
at just these elements in the topic
position without reading the rest of the
passage, could you predict what this
passage is about? Well, let's contrast
that with the topics that we find in
Csikszentmihalyi's version. We see in
the topic position of these clauses
happiness, happiness, happiness,
happiness, happiness. So, if you were to
zoom out and just say, "What is this
passage about?" The one in which all
these sentences are joining together.
What's it about? It's really easy to
say, "Happiness." And so, the difference
between the passage that's difficult to
read and easy to read has nothing to do
with grammar and everything to do with
organization. The information is
organized so that old familiar
information is in the topic position and
then all the new information comes at
the end of the sentence in what's called
the comment. And an easy way to think
about this topic and comment is to think
that the topic of a clause is kind of
like a doorstep and then the comment is
the room that the reader is going to
walk into. And so with that image in
mind, let me tell you about the first
writing framework. This is the perfect
framework to use whenever you want to
elaborate on a single topic, to add more
and more details to it. And in fact,
it's the pattern that Csikszentmihalyi
used in the passage that we just looked
at. So returning to that passage, we see
the first sentence says, "Happiness is
not something that happens." And so in
the topic position of this first
sentence, we have the word happiness.
And then we see all these pronouns and
the word happiness repeated, recurring
through every successive clause. All the
new complex information is developed in
the comment position and all the topics
are coherent. They're all linking back
to the same element. And so if you hold
on to that image of the topic being like
a doorstep, then this first pattern is
kind of like you're having the reader
stand there and look in the different
cardinal directions. There are multiple
ideas being developed and attached to
this single element that keeps in focus.
So as you see, this pattern is what
allows us to stay anchored on one topic
while developing multiple ideas about
it. And it's perfect for whenever you
are describing something or
characterizing something or just
developing a multifaceted idea. You
don't want the reader to get lost in all
the details and so this pattern allows
you to keep the reader anchored on the
one element that you want them to focus
on, and from that vantage point, they'll
be able to integrate all these ideas
that you develop, as we see here in the
passage about happiness. Now, this
pattern is really handy, but you should
be warned that it can create a kind of
stagnant feeling in the passage. So, you
really want to reserve it for moments
whenever you really need to elaborate on
something and unpack a single um or
multiple ideas about a single entity.
But, beware that it is going to make
your reader feel stuck, because they
are. They're standing on the doorstep
and they're looking in these different
directions. But, of course, you don't
always want the reader to be standing
still. Sometimes, you want to give them
some movement, and that's what the next
framework is for. And by the way, if you
want to take a closer look at these
frameworks, then you can get my free
visual guide to expert writing down
below the like button. It contains not
only these four frameworks, but actually
four pages of frameworks and patterns
that I've used to help writers make
their writing more clear and more
valuable. Totally free. Link is down
below the like button. So, what is this
second framework, and how can you use it
to give your writing a feeling of
momentum? Well, in the last section, we
talked about the framework being as
though you have the reader stood on a
doorstep and then turning them into
different cardinal directions. But, with
this framework, you want to imagine that
from the doorstep, the reader steps into
a room. And then from that room, they're
they're now standing in a new room. They
have a new vantage point, and the next
clause brings them into the next room.
Right? There's one step after the other.
And it's they're successive steps,
right? These aren't teleportations.
We're not jerking the reader around the
house one room to another. Everything is
linking one into the other. And in fact,
that's what the pattern is called, the
linking pattern. So, let me give you an
example of how this works. This comes
from James Gleick in his excellent book
Chaos: Making a New Science. So, the
passage says,
"Outside his window, Lorenz could watch
real weather. The early morning fog
creeping along the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology campus or the
low cloud slipping over the roofs from
the Atlantic." "Fog and clouds never
arose in the model running on his
computer.
The machine, a Royal McBee, was a
thicket of wiring and vacuum tubes that
occupied an ungainly portion of Lorenz's
office." And so, what we see with this
framework is that
each topic is linking back not to the
original topic, but to the end of the
previous clause. That is, it's picking
up the element that's in the comment and
using that as the next starting point.
And that's what gives it this sense of
forward momentum. So, we see the first
topic is outside his window, Lorenz.
Lorenz would be the first topic. And at
the end, we have two elements in the
comment position. We have fog and we
have clouds. Those are the elements that
are in the comment position. And then,
those elements get repeated, they're
linked back in this in the next topic.
Right? We see a fog and clouds. What
about them? They never arose in the
model running on his computer. And then,
computer becomes the topic of the next
clause, the machine a Royal McBee was a
thicket of wiring. And notice that at
the end of this clause, we are now
ending back where we began. Now, that's
not absolutely necessary. Um I'll give
you an example, but it's it's a nice
touch. And I'm going to give you another
example in a moment to show what can
happen when you don't kind of close this
loop. Um but just for the moment, notice
what's happening and how this gives the
passage this kind of forward motion.
Like, this kind of a pattern is
excellent for whenever you want the
reader to be moving through space. So,
that could be
in a in a passage where you're
describing travel, but it's also
excellent, you know, I work in an
academia, and so this is a really good
pattern for the method section of a
scientific report. But, it's really
useful for anything that involves
process, you know, one step after
another. If you need to show or like any
causal chain, this is framework that
you'd want to use. But, a moment ago I
mentioned that, you know, this is a nice
touch the way the Lorenz, the comment of
this passage, links back up to the topic
where we began. That's a nice touch
because watch what happens if we don't
have that kind of a closed loop. Here's
the same pattern. It's exactly the same
linking pattern, but what you're going
to notice is that it kind of falls
apart, and I wonder if you can see why.
Now, this passage is not from
professional prose, it's just something
I whipped up to prove a point, but see
if you can spot where it goes off the
rails. So, it says, "Soon Portland will
be the coffee roasting hub of the
nation.
The aroma of roasting beans fills the
streets, and gleaming espresso machines
line the counters. The machines remind
me of my dad's old typewriter, covered
with keys I would press randomly. His
typewriter always jammed on me. That's
why I avoided it.
I prefer to write on to write with blue
pen on yellow legal pads. This
preference has been the topic of heated
debates between me and my creative
writing professor. All right, now this
is exactly the same pattern. We have the
topic picking up the comment of the
previous clause. But, the problem is
that like when you zoom out and you look
at these topics just as we did at the
start here, when you just analyze the
topics, can you tell me what this
passage is about?
All right, let's let's take a closer
look. All right, this passage is about
Portland,
coffee beans,
espresso machines,
typewriter,
that I preference, creative writing
professor.
Like it's hard to see. One way to think
about it is to say like it's hard to
picture these elements on the same
stage. If these are all characters
in a play, then you might ask yourself
like what are they doing together?
Right? So, what is this passage about?
And that's what happens. It's like if
you start linking all these clauses
together, you get a nice experience of
flow or momentum, but as a writer, you
kind of need to keep them on track. In
other words, you need to keep everything
coherent. So, it works in this passage
about Lorenz because the author is kind
of taking us on a guided tour of his
office. We start looking at Lorenz, and
then we kind of zoom out a little bit
and look at the context of the
environment. We're kind of floating
around in space, and then we're
brought back to Lorenz. Now again, I
think there are different ways that you
can use this. I don't think you
necessarily always need to loop back
where you began, but you do need to be
careful about the way that you use this
pattern because it's it's kind of like
railroad tracks, and you don't want it
to take you too far off course. Now for
this third writing framework, you might
notice that it actually breaks a rule.
So, so far we've been talking about
repetition, and sometimes that
repetition happens just through
um repeating the word or using pronouns,
and in other cases, we have synonyms
being used. So, for example, uh the
machine, right? And uh the Royal McBee
replacing the machine, right? His
computer. So, we can use synonyms or
pronouns or just through repetition. But
for this third writing framework, you're
actually going to notice that it breaks
that rule entirely. We don't repeat the
same element in the topic positions, but
it still works. So let me read it for
you and see if you can see how this one
works. So this model passage by the way
comes from Steven Pinker and it says,
"When neuroscientists look directly at
the brain using a variety of techniques,
they can actually see language in action
in the left hemisphere.
The anatomy of the normal brain, its
bulges and creases, is slightly
asymmetrical.
In some of the regions associated with
language, the differences are large
enough to be seen with the naked eye.
Aphasic's brains almost always show
lesions in the left hemisphere." Right,
so if we examine the topics of all of
these successive clauses, we find that
there is no repetition. These are all
different elements. But somehow they do
seem to work together. I I don't know
about you, but I found that passage
pretty easy to read. And so what's the
difference between this passage and the
one that we just looked at about the
Portland coffee beans? Right, this one
about the Portland coffee beans seems
pretty incoherent, yet this one
from Steven Pinker works. Why is that?
Well, it's a little bit like walking
into a cathedral. Right, if you walk
into a cathedral, you're not going to be
very surprised to find inside the nave,
the crypt, and the pulpit. In other
words, once the whole is on stage,
you're not going to be surprised to see
its parts. And that's what's happening
here. We see the whole element being
introduced in the comment position, that
being the left hemisphere, which is the
language center of the brain. And then
different aspects of that one element
are introduced in all the successive
comments. We have the anatomy of the
normal brain being developed in one
comment. In the next clause, we have in
some regions associated with languages,
right over here. And then third, we have
aphasic brains. So, although these are
different topics, they're different
elements, right? The The topics are
indexing different things, those three
things are subsumed below the one topic,
the kind of general category that's
introduced in the comment position. And
this is an excellent pattern for
whatever you're providing a taxonomy or
just a kind of you're categorizing
something or you're just breaking down
one element into its various parts.
Although the parts are going to be
scattered and they're not going to be
renaming the same topic, whenever you
provide this kind of high-level
introduction of the the category on top
of it, almost like an umbrella, then it
lends coherence to the whole passage.
But for contrast, I think it's also
helpful to look at how this pattern can
go wrong. So, what I'd like to do now is
just read you another passage with
something missing and you can try to see
if you can tell what goes wrong with it.
And so, this passage, which follows the
same pattern, says "After gathering the
smallest and most colorful leaves from
the maples and oaks in our backyard, we
place the leaves between sheets of
blotter paper, which we then cover with
a large heavy book."
"In just a day or two, the leaves are
ready to be mounted on cards.
We use plain index cards folded in half.
Using clear adhesive paper, we put one
leaf on each card, leaving room for the
guest's name." Now, the first question
would be, how was that? Was that easy to
read? Well, I think we'd all agree no.
There's something wrong with that
passage.
Mosquito attack. And so, what is it
that's gone wrong with this passage?
Well, the thing that it's missing and
the the reason why it seems so kind of
incomprehensible or disjointed is that
it's missing this index clause, right?
If if you're going to have a passage
which names these varying topics, you
need to be specific in naming the
category or the kind of super theme that
joins them all together. If that theme
is only implied, right? If you don't
name it specifically where readers are
expecting to find it, then they're going
to find all the successive clauses in
this passage totally incoherent. And so,
if we were to introduce in the index
position a clause that kind of hangs
over them all as an umbrella, suddenly
they snap into place. Watch. Each
Thanksgiving we make place cards
decorated with pressed autumn leaves.
After gathering the smallest and most
colorful leaves from the maples and oaks
in our backyard, we place the leaves
between sheets of blotter paper, which
we then cover with a large heavy book.
In just a day or two, the leaves are
ready to be mounted on cards. We use
plain index cards folded in half. Using
clear adhesive paper, we put one leaf on
each card, leaving room for the guest's
name. Ah, like see, they all snap into
place. So, that tells you the importance
of having a kind of unifying um category
on top of it all. And this last writing
framework is excellent for whatever you
need to weave together multiple strands
into a single cohesive thread. And so,
keeping with the metaphor that we've
been developing here, if the topic is
like the doorstep where a reader arrives
before we present them with something
new, then the comment of this last
pattern is a little bit like a tour
guide approaching the reader and saying,
"We're going to go to this room, that
room, and this other room."
In other words, it's giving them a
preview of the major turns that they're
about to take. And so, let's watch this
in action and then I'll show you the
framework and how to use it. And so,
this example passage comes from Jonathan
Haidt. He's an excellent writer and this
passage occurs in his book The Righteous
Mind. And so, it says, "In their theory
of morality, Shweder et al. found three
major clusters of moral themes, which
they called the ethics of autonomy,
community, and divinity.
The ethic of autonomy is based on the
idea that people are first and foremost
autonomous individuals with wants,
needs, and preferences.
The ethic of community is based on the
idea that people are first and foremost
members of larger entities such as
families, teams, and armies, companies,
tribes, and nations.
The ethic of divinity is based on the
idea that people are first and foremost
temporary vessels within which a divine
soul has been implanted. And so, what
you might have spotted already is that
the comment of this first index clause
sets up A, B, and C. And then, those
elements that occur at the end of the
comment each get picked up in successive
clauses. A gets developed here, B gets
developed here, and C gets developed
here. So, that's why it's called a theme
preview. It's giving a reader a heads-up
of the three major turns that we're
about to take. But, a failure to watch
out for with this passage is the use of
synonyms. So, the reason this all snaps
together is because these words echo the
the terms the key terms that were put
out in the comment position of the first
clause. If we were to use a synonym
here, community such as like groups,
well, it wouldn't have the same cohesive
structure as using the same term or like
a very close not synonym, but um analog.
Like community and communal or autonomy
and autonomous. Those are fine because
they link back to the same key terms.
But, if you try to use synonyms here,
you're really kind of taxing the
reader's mental framework, because they
have to keep track of these three
elements. And if you can help them keep
track of that by repeating the same
terms, then they can snap the
information into this structure. Now,
we've been looking at these passages in
the context of paragraphs, but keep in
mind that these can occur at different
levels of resolution, and you can even
mix and match them. So, for example, in
a passage, if you can expand this
pattern out to an entire section, right?
You can imagine the introduction of a
section
uh announcing three major themes, and
then several paragraphs being given to
element A, and several paragraphs being
given to element B, and so on and so
forth, linking back with, you know,
major signposts like first, second,
third to help the reader keep track.
Then, within this macro structure, you
can introduce other patterns, such as
the linking pattern, right? You can go
old to new right? New information gets
picked up in the old information in that
kind of stepped linking pattern. In
whatever way you can. So, try to expand
this out into different levels of
resolution. And when you're done, you
need to watch this video next, because
it's going to give you five more
patterns that I see not only at the
level of sentence organization, but
across the entire essay. So, be sure to
go check it out.